guten morgen liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer aus dem bundestag hier in
berlin telekommunikations
modernisierungsgesetz sagen wir gleich
noch mehr dazu dazu gibt es auch ein
interview das ist nicht das einzige
thema im bundestag
es geht auch in den digitalen impfpass
oder um kinder und jugendhilfe dass im
laufe des vormittags die eigentliche
musik spielt natürlich im bundesrat nach
dem gestern ja hier das
infektionsschutzgesetz verabschiedet
worden ist jetzt ist der bundesrat dann
allerdings erst gegen 11 uhr dann 15
kilometer südlich von hier muss der
bundesrat noch dem infektions gesetz
zustimmen obwohl es ja nur ein einspruch
und kein zustimmungsgesetz ist aber der
bundesrat wird nach lage der dinge zu
stimmen wirecard untersuchungsausschuss
gibt es heute auch noch der knöpft sich
zunächst mal olaf scholz vor und morgen
kommt dann ja auch die bundeskanzlerin
in diesen untersuchungsausschuss im
bundestag gesagt business as usual aber
ein außerordentlich wichtiges thema das
jeden von uns betrifft es geht um
kommunikation um schnelles internet
erreichbarkeit um sicherheit und auch um
unser geld und um nicht wenig geld und
dazu begrüße ich jetzt hier bei uns
tabea rößner von bündnis 90 die grünen
sind die sprecherin für netzpolitik und
verbraucherpolitik und tankred
schipanski ist von der cdu csu fraktion
und dort sprecher wie dieser bereich
dort genannt wird digitale agenda frau
roßner schnelles internet bis ins
kleinste dorf das ja die forderung hilft
dafür jetzt dieses telekommunikations
modernisierungsgesetz dass der heute im
bundestag verabschiedet wird also
zunächst muss man mal sagen dieses
gesetzes so umfangreich dass regelt hat
sehr sehr viel
das regelt einmal die frage des
schnellen internets des ausbaus der
verbraucher verträge beispielsweise und
es gab immer die ankündigung es soll ein
recht auf schnelles internet geben das
heißt für mich und für uns wir fordern
dass auch dass ein teil der
daseinsvorsorge ist das heißt auch einen
rechtsanspruch und zwar dessen was die
eu ermöglicht denn es ist ja die
umsetzung von eu-vorgaben und dass es
leider so nicht erfüllt ist es nur eine
minimal version dessen was möglich ist
deshalb glaube ich nicht dass es das
schnelle internet auch in die ländlichen
räume wirklich voranbringt
die anspruch recht auf schnelles
internet wir haben in deutschland das
ist die voraussetzung in deutschland ist
dafür ja dass es einen
glasfaseranschluss gibt das haben glaube
ich 14 prozent der menschen bei uns in
lettland eu-mitglied nicht weit weg von
uns sind es 90 prozent waren ist denn
diese voll versorgung mit schnellem
internet bei uns erreicht eine gute
frage
wir müssen ja festhalten es ist eine
aufgabe der daseinsvorsorge wie strom
wie wasser und dafür sind die kommunen
zuständig der bund selber macht
umfangreiche förderprogramme um solche
glasfaserausbau voranzutreiben
und ich glaube dieses gesetz gibt jetzt
insbesondere auch den kommunen noch mal
rückhalt wenn sie sehen wenn wir
breitbandausbau machen wir ein
markterkundungsverfahren da mussten
bisher die tk-unternehmen nicht klar
sagen baue ich ausbau ich nicht aus das
ist jetzt geschichte man muss dem
bürgermeister und dem landrat vor ort
sagen jawoll bis dahin dahin baue ich
aus man muss sich rechtlich
verpflichtend festlegen
ich glaube das ist ein wichtiger
meilenstein wir entschlacken das gesamte
genehmigungsverfahren bei dem
glasfaserausbau und wir führen da muss
ich tabea rößner nicht ganz recht geben
ein recht auf internet anschluss ein
sagen die idee eu es möchte wir machen
das internet den internetanschluss zu
einem universaldienst und somit hat der
bürger ein anspruch auf einen
internetanschluss in deutschland es
würde jetzt angekündigt dass das so
kommen soll jetzt hat ja die korona
krise an den tag gebracht dass wir zum
teil der in manchen teil ist ehrlich
trostlos aussieht im bereich mobile
endgeräte bei der leitungsstruktur
homeschooling home office
gesundheitsversorgung sind das nicht
viel zu viele baustellen auf einmal als
dass man den bürger jetzt sagen kann
also in wenigen jahren seid ihr was
kommunikation dass eure persönliche
kommunikation angeht voll versorgt er
das ist ja das traurige seitlich im
bundestag bin das im 12 jahre kämpfen
wir dafür dass es diesen rechtsanspruch
gibt und dass es auch schneller
ausgebaut wird und es gab immer sehr
wenig ambitionierte ziele wie der ausbau
auch vonstatten gehen soll es gab
förderprogramme die auch nicht ziel
führend waren die genehmigungsverfahren
zum teil 11 jahre und die frage ist ja
tatsächlich was ist der rechtsanspruch
mal mir nützt es nichts wenn ich den
rechtsanspruch auf eine geringe
downloadrate zb habe und das bild dann
trotzdem ruckelt sondern es muss so
ausgestaltet sein dass tatsächlich auch
hohe bandbreiten dann in den anspruch
erwirken kann und deshalb haben wir zum
beispiel auch gesagt für die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher muss es
einen schadenersatzanspruch geben wenn
ich das was ich von den anbietern
vertraglich auch zugesichert bekommen
habe wenn ich das nicht bekomme da muss
sich das durchsetzen können und das
sieht der gesetzentwurf leider nicht vor
nochmal die ankündigung das soll jetzt
bald kommen dass man ist da dran sie
haben ja auch gesagt wer dafür zuständig
ist der bürger nehmen das jetzt zur
kenntnis und merkt in zwei drei jahren
bei mir ist immer noch nichts angekommen
sie erleben das war eine schlechte
prioritätensetzung in den kommunen jetzt
werden diese förderprogramme wesentlich
besser abgerufen es geht schneller voran
beim ausbau wir machen aber weitere
erleichterungen sie müssen sich
vorstellen wir geben jetzt mit diesem
gesetz so genannten mit
nutzungsmöglichkeiten den einzelnen tk
unternehmen beim thema glasfaser auch
das große thema roaming was beim
mobilfunk sehr umstritten war wird jetzt
hier nochmal ganz klar geregelt und eine
roaming verpflichtung aufgelegt wir
erlauben den tk anbietern bei einem
marktbeherrschenden unternehmen wie die
telekom an die baulichen anlagen
ranzugehen an die kästen zu kommen um
auch zügiger zu versorgen und ein ganz
wichtiges thema für mieterinnen und
mieter wir kippen das sogenannte
nebenkosten privileg wo man für seinen
kabelanschluss zahlen musste gebunden
war an das was der vermieter gemacht hat
bauen das um zu einer echten
glasfaserausbau anspruch dass also jetzt
in die mietshäuser glasfaser gelegt wird
und dann der mieter entscheiden kann
welchen anbieter wähle ich für mein
festnetz schumann fernsehangebot und das
ist glaube ich denke ich ist auch als 20
24 so ehrlich muss man sein aber wir
schaffen mit diesem gesetz diese
grundlage
es wird ja in der via viel gejammert ob
zu recht oder zu unrecht über den
beklagenswerten zustand ja man tun auch
die unternehmen wie sich für die
wirtschaft die über unzureichendes
internet sagt gleichzeitig zu hohe
kosten reduziert was sagen sie da naja
die anbieter klagen immer das sind ich
möchte sie insgesamt die wirtschaft die
ja auf schnelles internet auch
angewiesen ist julian wichtiger ist es
dass man ambitionierte ziele hat und das
was das gesetz vorsieht ist wirklich nur
eine minimal version und das sagten auch
die sachverständigen bei der anhörung
das ist nicht ambitioniert genug und
wenn wir tatsächlich in die zukunft
schauen was die zukunftsaufgabe ist
gerade auch für die wirtschaft dann
sollte es auch anders geregelt werden
nämlich dass es hohe bandbreiten gibt
dass es ein rechtsanspruch auf hohe
bandbreiten gibt und dass die auch
durchsetzbar sind gegenüber den
anbietern bei in der tk-branche generell
ist viel geld unterwegs es gibt viel
geld in die förderprogramme und von
daher glaube ich dass es wichtig ist
dass verbraucherfreundlich
auszugestalten
schipanski bleiben noch im moment bei
den unternehmen jetzt in dem fall auch
noch bei der ganzen wirtschaft nicht nur
bei der it branche wird da zu wenig
investiert vor allem auch in
it-sicherheit immer wieder hört man ja
dass gerade kleine und mittlere
unternehmen
da viel zu wenig machen viel zu
leichtsinnig sind hacker industriespione
haben dann leichtes spiel sich in den
unternehmen zu bedienen
ich glaube das ist eine frage der
prioritätensetzung wie es damals bei den
kommunen beim breitbandausbau ist das
jetzt natürlich bei dem unternehmen das
thema it-sicherheit ein zaun um sein
gebäude hat jedes unternehmen aber sie
haben recht eine ordentliche firewall
eine ordentliche it-sicherheit die
wenigsten aber ich glaube da haben wir
gut sensibilisiert auch morgen
verabschieden wir dazu noch das
sicherheitsgesetz 2.0 was insbesondere
das bsi das bundesamt für sicherheit in
der informationstechnik noch einmal
stärkt auch in eine beratungsfunktion
für verbraucher für unternehmer
also ich glaube da sind wir auch auf
einem guten weg
das problem ist aus dem tkg und auch dem
telemediengesetz wären guten schützen
gewährten datenschutzfragen
herausgenommen und die sollen in einem
eigenen gesetz noch einmal geklärt
werden
es gibt verfassungsrechtliche bedenken
es gibt fragen des datenschutzes die
berührt sind der
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte hat das
kritisiert also dass es auch wichtig da
nochmal genauer hinzuschauen und für
rechtssicherheit sorgen einmal zur
rechtlich hyde der wirtschaft aber auch
um das recht der informationellen
selbstbestimmung auch durch da komme ich
gleich drauf zur wirtschaft passt ja
auch das thema verbraucherschutz
wenn ich jetzt höre also
internetgeschwindigkeit bandbreite auch
die sogenannte übertragungsrate ist das
einklagbar
für den für den einzelnen bürger bürger
der theoretisch ist es einklagbar aber
es gibt viele schlupflöcher und insofern
wird es schwierig sein dass tatsächlich
zu machen
schwierig ist auch beispielsweise was
die vertragslängen angeht das ist auch
nicht besonders verbraucherfreundlich
gestaltet also gerade bei dem
verbraucher fragen hätte man die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher noch
mal ein bisschen mehr stärken können das
war eigentlich eine ankündigung der
regierung und das ist leider so nicht
erfüllt entspannt geht gleich noch mit
einer frage hinterher die branche die it
branche beklagt überregulierung oder
befürchtet überregulierung also die
branche befürchtet immer über
regulierungen aber das heißt in dem fall
dass wir insbesondere marktbeherrschende
unternehmen zwingen ihre netze zu öffnen
ihre baulichen anlagen zu öffnen das ist
gut für wettbewerb das ist gut für den
kunden von der rg das gesetz in die
richtige richtung und für den kunden
glaube ich verbessert sich eine ganze
menge
bisher konnte ich wenn ich die
entsprechende bandbreite nicht erhalten
habe nur über ein
streitschlichtungsverfahren zur
bundesnetzagentur gegen das ist jetzt
geschichte
wir schaffen einen echten
minderungsansprüche des kunden gegenüber
seinen telekommunikationsanbieter das
denke ich einen meilenstein den wir das
schaffen wir haben vorangebracht dass er
der kunde einen anspruch haut auf
entstörung seines anspruchs innerhalb
von zwei tagen wie wir das von wasser
von stromversorgung bei dingen der
daseinsvorsorge auch kennen und ein ganz
wichtiger punkt die vertragslaufzeiten
tabea rößner hat es angesprochen
wir hatten bisher größtenteils für
festnetz und mobilfunk immer 24 monats
verträge
das ändern wir jetzt auch die anbieter
müssen zwölf monats verträge anbieten
müssen datenschutz kommen wenn es um
vorratsdatenspeicherung also die
kontrolle von telekommunikations verkehr
durch behörden geht oder krone at da
sind viele auf den barrikaden wenig
zimperlich sind sie allerdings wenn sie
ihre privaten daten an private anbieter
wie facebook übermitteln sollen sind da
viele internet-nutzer auf einem auge
blind
naja der widerspruch den gibt es zum
teil schon aber es ist ja schon die
frage ob es eine anlasslose
vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt und auch da
hatte die bundesregierung uns eigentlich
geantwortet sie will abwarten wie das
urteil des europäischen gerichtshofes zu
der vorratsdaten
die speicherung erfolgt und erst danach
die regelung klar zieht aber das ist
nicht erfolgt und insofern haben wir da
große bedenken ist es dann wunder wenn
man das also diese diese dieses diesen
widerspruch einerseits meine daten
gehören mir auf der anderen seite sie so
offenherzig auf den markt zu bringen
dass 71 prozent der internetnutzer nach
einer umfrage glauben sie hätten die
kontrolle über ihre daten verloren
das ist eine gesetzgebung die idee die
tabea rößner schon angesprochen hat die
wir in der ersten maiwoche hier noch
einmal behandeln nämlich wie der
datenschutz bei telekommunikation und
telemedien aus wir wollen da ein
sogenanntes daten cockpit einführen das
genau wie sie das beschreiben der
nutzerdaten souverän sagen kann ich
stelle die und die voreinstellungen in
meinem browser ein dienen die daten gebe
ich frei die dürfen genutzt werden und
das kann man mit hilfe von technischen
voreinstellung machen das wollen wir nun
auch gesetzlich ermöglichen allerdings
nicht in diesem gesetz bei diesem gesetz
und darauf möchte ich hinweisen ist es
uns insbesondere gelungen dieses ganze
thema front door ausleiten für
nachrichtendienste aufspielen von
sicherheits software durch die
tk-unternehmen rauszunehmen dass damit
wird das gesetz nicht belastet und ich
glaube das ist auch ein ganz wichtiger
punkt den wir auch versprochen haben und
jetzt aber dass diese gesetze dann auch
parallel in kraft treten ja sonst gibt
es nämlich eine lücke ich will trotzdem
noch auf einen widerspruch hinweise und
nochmal wiederholt es gibt eine weitere
umfrage fast die hälfte der
internetnutzer sind bereit ihre daten zu
verkaufen
worüber reden wir jetzt eigentlich beim
datenschutz die frage ist ja ob ich
freiwillig meine daten zur verfügung
stelle
und vielleicht auch verkaufe oder ob im
hintergrund meine daten ausgespielt
werden bestandsdaten ausgespielt werden
und das ohne anlass in eine speicherung
erfolgt ich glaube da hat jeder bürger
und jede bürgerin das recht darauf zu
pochen dass das nicht passiert zu wenig
sensibel mit unseren daten
das glaube ich nicht wir haben eine
daten wirtschaftdaten sind auch kapital
das ist auch ein geschäftsmodell und da
ist es richtig dass auch zu
monetarisieren
aber da wir müssen als angesprochen das
darf nicht im hintergrund im geheimen
passieren sondern der bürger muss wissen
wann hat wer welche daten wann kann ich
das verkaufen und damit wegen wir ebnen
wir auch den weg dann für einen modernen
datenschutz im tk nicht
tabea rößner von bündnis 90 die grünen
tankred schipanski eben von der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion danke für das
gespräch
sie müssen rein es geht gleich los